hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to SCP containment breach
now this isn't the original SCP
containment breach that you all have
seen before this is the unity engine
remake of SCP containment breach and you
guys have said that it's a pretty
faithful recreation so I'm not a hundred
percent sure what to expect out of it
all I know is that the graphics will be
better the implementation of updates to
the game will be more modern and easier
to do because the old engine that the
game was even programmed on isn't
supported anymore so we'll see what
happens now it's not to the same level
of detail that the other game was I can
guarantee you that there won't be as
many SCPs there won't be everything and
anything that was in SCP containment
breach when I played it before even
after a couple updates even though there
haven't been that many but this is made
by another team and should be pretty
good
oh boy what aah Oh hate it already I
just got in here and I already hate it
oh boy oh boy oh this is awful I mean
this is nice but I just got all the
heebie-jeebies from the original game
can I pick up your flashlight do you
have a gun that I could steal yes you do
you do have a pistol I could steal but
I'm not gonna do it cuz I'm oh nice hand
alright alright how oh [ __ ] is this
Billy's containment room I don't notice
all the the the fecal matter on the
floor alright well I suppose that
everything's gonna be fine then I have a
health bar which is a dear friend I hate
it I hate it that looks too good it's
too realistic I liked it better when
everything look like a potato
so I again I don't know how much detail
is in the game but I can already tell it
feels better it probably works better
and it's probably scarier when they
actually come after me and he's still
randomly generated so everything is
gonna be new and interesting or none
that yeah where I came in
that's where I came in what is this
alternate vent ventilation [ __ ] all
right done [ __ ] up um sorry I'm sorry
what did I do
okay-y places it well why is there an
option to lock myself in here
no I don't like that okay all right then
well no no again don't like the music I
don't like anything happening that I
don't understand what's happening
whoo
oh it's that room oh I remember this is
a horrible room please don't let anyone
be in here oh I'm sorry
hi okay that's a problem all right
so Billy is active and is following us
which is bad okay all right well we got
to find another way to go out of here I
should probably close everything behind
me I don't get snuck up on inside of my
but I'll find a Billy so I know if
there's Billy here I don't think there's
too many other scps but I know that he's
gonna be a goddamn son of a [ __ ] isn't
he I got a hit I can remember all my SCP
habits like blinking before I open a
door you know just for safety reasons so
I don't end up bling blong and right in
front of a Billy Willy
oh is this a big circle wait this is
just a circle back to where yeah yeah
it's just a circle I'm not gonna go back
in there
what are you crazy I'm gonna go back the
way I came try to find me another way
out of here
oh I also don't like the way the one
mixed up the room all war pee okay so
far so good really did you break out of
your containment good I don't know if he
can open doors in this version but I'm
not tempted to find out I think if I go
this way they'll be another yeah if I
make it right here my innate sense of
direction and expert gaming skills are
telling me that I need to go this way oh
wait
um you wipe I don't know what that is
what is that
Zen a mannequin why is it white what is
DP is a mannequin but I want that okay
all right then fine said I go charging
face-first do not enter
des Tambor without protective equipment
but what the [ __ ] do i do [ __ ] all right
what the [ __ ] I don't know what you do
and I don't know why
oh that's awful oh well that's the worst
it's my nightmare oh my god damn
nightmare it's my nightmare it's my
goddamn nightmare oh oh no no okay
little lag come on
okay he's not in this room and that's
good
containment breach blip a flap up I
don't understand can I do an unlock down
there's something that I can actually
control here okay I don't know why that
thing didn't follow me in here follow me
everywhere else might as well keep okay
well I guess it's just gone then maybe
you can break my heart someday okay oh
this looks bad oh oh oh
glasses whoa a trash ball I don't know
what are you oh hi doc Oh rubber duckie
well I got a rubber duckie now is that
good or bad is it like the Bell should I
Bing bong it oh boy it's a it's a bowl
of candy hmm take no more than two
please okay but what is and where's my
here we go what the hell considering
recent incidents scp-339 secure storage
until further notice level Duke
clearance is required for access to
scp-339 so I'll direct experimentation
of SCP 3:30 is to be conducted we using
Class D personnel with no genetic
history of diabetes no more than two
samples are to be removed from SCP 338
anytime except during exposure testing
SCP 330 will appears to be small round
stainless steel bowl filled with a
variable amount of individually wrapped
pieces of candy taped to the side of the
bowl is a handwritten note reading take
nor more than two please attempts to
remove the note have met with failure as
I have attempts to hide or obscure it
testers have noted finding it impossible
to avoid reading the note and those who
approach you from an opposite angle are
aware of this request when a quantity of
Candida greater than two pieces is
removed or regardless of the means
evolved the offender instantly has both
hands sever to the
risk by unknown method test involving
remote manipulation by Class D personnel
resulted in the operators hand being
removed despite no direct contact
inspection of the incision reveals that
the cut is made at the molecular level
leaving milk tool marks or identifying
factors it is to be noted that the third
piece must be removed within a certain
time frame after 24 hours the count
resets an additional candy can be
removed since dr. Omar is unable to
control his appetite during his mood
swings s CB 3:30
okay alright Wow alright well how do I
save how can I save I can't save I can't
save but I gotta get that candy but I
gotta but I gotta one oh all right well
that's good I got two candies can I eat
them nope three hi what are you doing
here my hands I don't have any hands
anymore well you and me both
hey buddy we're just friend lend Oh God
oh I'm spewing ball my hands
god I'm dripping blood I think I'm gonna
perish it some point soon I can't open
it up well well they don't eat candy Oh
call myself markiplier oh god okay I'll
be right back alright who you know I
didn't notice that there was an upstairs
before so I'm gonna peruse this area ah
this seems like an area that I should
have gone first yes I am extremely
thirsty and dumb oh I don't understand
this my brains not big enough
we got a radio piece of paper some kind
of computer whatever this is
some kind of observation chamber of some
sort for quote-unquote testing I mean
you'd think that they would understand
it after a little bit but a more testing
okay computer ain't working all right
there was nothing to be gained by going
up here but I still feel good for doing
it
well let's skedaddle on down and meet
our fate with our new friends okay so
for future reference f5 is quicksave
which I'm going to use a lot because I'm
probably going to die a lot I'm about to
die again okay it's uh Oh ducky that
ducky
how you doing friend you're coming with
mood all right
I'm not I'm just gonna take - Alexa shut
up scared the piss out of me all right -
just - no more than do one for me and
one for ducky and ducky we're gonna have
good time okay what is this what what
are you as the SCP 170s to be stored in
a class three anomalous object object
container guarded by no fewer than two
armed personnel with level three
clearance when not undergoing testing
item is to be removed from containment
only with the written permission of
personnel with level four clearance or
higher scp-172 is a pair of white
stereoscopic 3d glasses with a
rectangular white cardboard frame and
lenses of transparent blue and red left
and right lenses respectively plastic
the item exhibits no unusual physical
properties apart from the slight
discoloration of the cardboard
consistent with age when worn the weir
wearer begins perceiving large bipedal
entities in addition to its ordinary
surroundings entities reportedly
exhibited docile and occasionally
curious behavior reports include engines
leading over the shoulder of the person
working and observing them with interest
with one exception any attempt by the
wearer or any personnel to directly
interact with the end of these results
in severe lacerations suddenly appearing
on the person's involved the appearance
of laceration is rapid and continues
until the moment the wearer expires the
pattern of lacerations is always
consistent with beings
no no what Dad I can't radical Mary hi
well this is new hi
hi friend oh you look so good oh that's
nice that's that's really nice I really
dig good close to you well I'm Way too
close I'm touching you I'm touching you
I lost all right I was trying to read
what happened I glued well I mean quick
save okay so I'm back here let me put
quick save yeah I just did that creepy
sound three parallel tapered sharp
objects of lengths of varying between
fourteen point two okay all right yeah
it's bad basically what they're saying
okay hi friends how are you I'm doing
you want to lacerate me hellooo no oh
right hey hey hey hey what the hell you
do she's that for hey let me take off my
glove oh I'm almost dead oh well no I am
dead
oh well poop my pants and call me Steve
oh alright
statute is out of possess hands or
facial features the limbs taper off into
rounded points and the head is a smooth
surface all around okay well what else
if the statute is not being observed it
will wreak locate itself to a point
immediately behind whomever is in the
containment site and assuming a
threatening pose is just threatening
however should be noted that SB has not
yet shown any signs of active aggression
or hostility its purpose does not seem
to be to attack but merely to startle oh
yeah just just startled huh well well
my pants and call me Roger I don't
believe that for a single second I am
NOT going to trust it it was just like
I'm not gonna trust anything in this
game I'm not gonna trust it it's bad so
I'm not trusting it everything in this
game looks bad so I mean it looked good
but looks like it's bad for my health
which is generally why I don't trust it
hello there's someone there anybody just
endless hallways forever and ever oh oh
oh this is this is the one isn't it ah
well ha oh no no where you at
huh okay I don't like that it's time for
both okay but [ __ ] god [ __ ] you why
did I have to let you out of your cage I
don't like that okay you're gonna be
following me around forever you're just
gonna spook me there's nothing but a
spook huh oh yeah uh-huh okay all right
okay oh ah what is this what is this the
use of cameras and our video equipment
is prohibited everybody shut off your
computers you only you can only listen
to this audio only I think huh [ __ ]
every goddamn time every goddamn time
[Music]
why were no cameras why we're no camera
equipment allowed why oh why no why no
that no why
but but why though oh the oh this is I
know what this is the high-res version
of the da da da they think that it's
gonna be there yeah I think I did I lose
my buddy I think I might've lost my
buddy okay close that what do we got
here we got two new notes what do we got
let's see oh that's the gas mask I think
I've read about the gas mask before yes
yeah you go to a different world was
this one oh scp-500 that's the that's
the heal anything pill I believe so this
whoa okay that's not there anymore
all right someone took that mmm gas
masks
okay we let's try it let's see what it
do yep
that's weird
a little strange girls go neighbor are
you doing oh nice face and not why don't
be like that
anything you're wonderful my mannequin
buddy is gonna appear up over here whoa
what what are you doing what are you
doing
back up out of my face I'll slap you
with the back enema I'll slap you
okay I'm back now all right that was a
fun adventure I'm glad I did that
I'm sure there will be no psychological
repercussion for me putting that on
myself
oh good long ominous hallway pretty sure
every hallway in this game is long and
ominous where are you taking me where am
I going man I'm going so deep into this
complex I just don't understand oh hi
okay well that's a problem um how far do
you go
okay don't like that that's all right
wave my back on it that's the best idea
oh that's oh that's an elevator I don't
like an elevator no I like it up down
okay
swing it all around okay well we're
going down for some reason
I don't know why but here we go I can't
breathe but I'm not gonna put it on okay
well I'm dying
oh you're dying gasps what the [ __ ]
happened what happened it's something
Billy break my neck oh those things
those things are probably down there all
right so we're not going down there all
right now anyway we need a gas mask at
least I'm assuming we do
[Music]
yes now Oh nope don't like it definitely
do not like oh that's a big no like okay
alright where are you taking me what is
this what is that you object class safe
contain my ass I can't contain your ass
it's Pro dishes ask earth is just too
much for our containment proceed what is
this it's beautiful whatever it is okay
all right um butterflies hey you said
this was safe oh [ __ ]
please stop maybe I should have read the
SCP report well let's let's actually
read something here huh let's read wasp
response mr. Aiken oh wait here we go to
whoever's in charge of this project my
team and I refuse to work in the tunnels
as long as those damn bugs are using the
digging site for their nests the men
can't do a single [ __ ] thing without
being torn to shreds by their wings if
you want us to get our work done get rid
of the stupid things or find a new spot
to expand concerning the site expansion
tunnel the other researchers and I think
it would why oh oh hi that's problem I'm
gonna blink blog doooo you dare don't
you dare don't you dare this is not the
right way this is not the right way I
don't like that don't like that at all
I hear you scooting I hear you scoot in
your boot I'm trying to read god dammit
I just want to read I didn't even grab
the health all right for the time being
the town on the surface is temporary
containment chamber while the original
chambers repaired await further
instruction from site director okay why
what do we do
what's happening we got out he's where
okay whatever I don't like it shockingly
I don't like it does this lead anywhere
[Music]
wall
well found this machine I don't know if
there's gonna be any good for me because
I don't really have anything I mean I
got no I have nothing what happened all
by [ __ ] what happened did those goddamn
all those goddamn butterflies they stole
all my garbage what if I throw myself in
here oh yeah here we go yeah I'm in I'm
in baby chomp me
[Music]
am i nope can't run no I'm alive didn't
didn't think though god I thought I'd be
crushed
alright okay nine one four reet I can't
root there's nothing here there's
nothing there's nothing here
alright well that's weird I'm not gonna
save cuz I still have a funny feeling
that I'm not gonna be okay after that
but shockingly I am by just a more
handsome version of myself
how fine am i how very fine am i all
right whatever
well God now can't save for fear of
losing all my perverse this is yeah okay
what do we got
whoa well that's not what I was
expecting
what is you what are you what are you
what are you seven one four it's oh the
green jade ring that's right
this is the one that causes like it's a
shielding from certain mimetic effects
which is probably only useful in one or
two scenarios there's nothing in here
there's nothing here whoa what's this
them nothing they've both been pokin
somebody Newcombe jeez I don't know eeny
meeny miny moe
Oh in a big [ __ ] circle we won't go Oh
nope nope no no no
oh no no no whoa whoa whoa wait whoa
wait whoa that's a problem okay now I
just gotta see if I can find my way back
and I'm not a hundred percent sure I'm
going the right way but oh well what is
that I don't like that we do you know I
do feel a little okay okay I think I
made my way back to here which is good I
don't know how I didn't think this
connected to that okay I want to write
last time I'll go to left hopefully
enough it's just all gonna circle back
into one big circle jerk huh all right
sure
whatever doesn't even go anywhere
what's the point of the ventilation
system what is ventilating the place
gonna do blood oh okay
that's a ventilation system but the one
thing this game does that good like for
a for a remake is it just captures the
same sense of paranoia and fear
okay all right well I can't move anymore
okay well I guess I don't have a choice
okay all right I guess I can't even find
it huh nope I couldn't even pull away if
I tried
[Music]
okay yes there I go there's a stabby
stabby righty righty well this is what
it takes to be a singer-songwriter
[Applause]
apparently I guess I'm just gonna stay
here all right I think you're nice look
good in some rice I don't think you've
got much left I hope to be in your clam
I don't know see what we could be you
and me I want to face I'm dead now
okay never got to finish that song I
just never got to finish it as such a
shame such a shame that the world will
never know how that song ends so let's
just not go there let's just does it
make a promise to each other you and I
that we're not gonna go in there because
that is bad that's bad place oh wait am
I going to wait I'm going backwards
sorry no you and me we're gonna promise
we're not gonna go backwards anymore
right guys right definitely
okay so I think I've reached the end of
the road with this area I don't know if
there's anything left to explore like I
said I don't know how complete this game
is it's relatively recent that they were
doing a recreation but got it man it's
pretty faithful
Oh whoa what is this I don't know this
is what is this this is what is this
where am i this is nothing I don't like
that it's just nothing
makes me think that there may be some in
here and I just kind of let it out maybe
it's like a security checkpoint for the
the next security area once they get
that implemented into the game okay so I
found that but it's not ready for me it
not ready for all my awesome I'll save
my awesome for later then this game gets
updated is this game guns get updated I
will play it again like a substantial
update with a lot more scps because he's
really cool like it's cool to finally
see this game come to life in a bigger
way
oh this in a bigger way than I've seen
before you know but I think there's a
bit of a bug because every time you load
a quicksave seems like all your items go
away so this goes to show don't die
don't die hopefully which is definitely
an easy thing to avoid in this game
where everything wants to kill you
definitely easy oh yeah this oh okay
don't have a gas mask or anything so I
don't I mean I could try to go down here
again but something tells me it's gonna
go just as poorly as it did this last
time don't have a gas mask so I'm kind
of cool I mean there's that horrible gas
mask let's do this I'm sprinting to the
finish I'm doing it mmm I don't like
this
oh maybe not maybe not if this is this
is the another elevator it's not okay
it's not it's not another elevator I'm
dead well that well that kind of dict me
over a little bit huh well I guess
there's just no way out of that is there
it's just a loop you loop into a bit of
death great
okay just skipping out on the elevator
again because screw that [ __ ] I don't
need to drop down into a pit of hell I'm
already in a living hell right here this
is hell as far as the eye can see
oh it's another elevator well alright
then my adventurous instincts telling me
to go down hope it's not filled with
Harv what is this [ __ ] where am I going
why there stirs nice don't seem good oh
well [ __ ] me then oh it's upstairs in
the in the it's upstairs can I close
this is this hell can I use it please
close it maybe I can breathe nope can't
breathe okay gonna die well [ __ ] [ __ ]
how the [ __ ] you're gonna how the [ __ ]
I got to get a goddamn gas mask
alright so screw the goddamn elevators
there's no way that I can actually get
well don't like it we don't like alright
it's fine it's fine spine is fine we're
fine
yeah what was even the point of that
that probably just bypassed a little bit
of area voom yeah
please don't thank you I guess
okay feel violated don't know why but I
feel violated find that open dad what
the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] what that fact
it's better cycle he's just a big circle
I just went in a goddamn cycle
well [ __ ] me alright a little bit easier
if I had just done that I could have
avoided me some herbal Hey Oh what is
this
level one why would you know we're gonna
go over here
haha come to me me oh don't like it
don't like it don't like it nice ass
don't like it
yeah I don't like it no no no no say V
wavy okay if you hear that I need
nothing why would someone stationed up
under their stairwell that doesn't make
a lot of sense but okay alright whatever
okay level 2 is in lockdown which is
probably for the best I would expect
that a lot of things to be in lockdown
but level 3 is so open oh oh [ __ ] where
the hell is where's this base located
I'm kind of frozen north and or south
not and or I guess OOP gas mask battery
and paper no gas mask okay
that's not what I was hoping for so it
must be down here right where yeah you
down here
what is this [ __ ]
where's the goddamn gas masks I don't
like it
can I at least get some light reading
done without my neck being snapped out
of my own ass
probably not what is this oh the winget
organism butterfly okay 173 special
incident report SCP 104 8 - a was
discovered wandering site 24 accompanied
by SCP 104 8 suspect resembles a teddy
bear similar in size to shape made
entirely out of oh that's the the bear
the by admire the bad bear made of human
ears and it's friend the bear okay well
that was useful wish I had a gas mask
but there probably it might not be
implemented yet so you never know what
these things could just be that I need
to wait for an update before they got
the gas masks until then I guess I'm
just stuck playing rope-a-dope with
freakin Billy Oh Billy's gone okay well
that's good that's real good HAP about
vibe it's not that oh no I have been
here okay so I've officially made it
back to where I was before which is
really good Oh another one of these wait
why is why is that saying the door you
can go through there a way to go through
that door
probably not raaah just a bunch of
[ __ ] huh is buddy here Oh buddy ah
god damn it okay well we have that to
look forward to now okay you there you
there
oh you there where are you I don't like
this god damn it you're good at that
you're real good at that I don't
at all but [ __ ] oh you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
all right well that's nice that's real
nice if I just don't look behind me I
don't have anything to worry about
right ha ha you thought you had me the
answer was that you did not huh no no no
no no no no Nana Nana okay well this is
problem
this brought why where to go what the
[ __ ] that's not fair oh that is not how
I thought that was going to go down Oh
what is this
oh [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] okay well how about
how about you want some candy you want
some candy
oh well that's not good
all right so that is the current state
of SCP the PPP that is the current state
of SCP containment breach the unity
freemake there's a lot of good stuff
going on here it's a very faithful
recreation to the game so I encourage
the developers to keep continuing if you
guys want to help out and support the
developers and encourage them to develop
more into this game we could see
something really cool and special and
this this version of the game is still
free so check it out I'll provide a link
in the description if you for some
reason want to scare the crap out of
yourself and thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video but I
[Music]